let's stay in louisiana to maria
villarreal who is in hard hit houma
louisiana near where hurricane ida made
landfall mora national guard troops are
helping with search and rescue and crews
are working to clear the roads what are
the people there telling you
we may not have marea
so here's what's going on here this is
what people are telling us it doesn't
matter what part of houma you live in
everything looks the same this used to
be a save a lot grocery store the roof
has come down the windows are shattered
there is debris everywhere the
destruction all looks the same here
right but the one thing we can tell you
is that people are trying to pick up the
pieces there is a curfew in place it
starts at sunset and it ends at sunrise
that's to keep people off of the
roadways it's also to keep businesses
like this safe from potential looters
all over houma louisiana this morning
residents are picking up the pieces of
hurricane ida frank marshall has lived
in his trailer for 21 years cherish your
family
it's a
it's good to have family
we'll make it though
i know somebody would be there to give
me a hand so
excuse me guys god bless y'all celebrity
chef jose andres and the world central
kitchen offered people without homes
here and in new orleans a little home
cooking
we're doing thousands of meals today
between hot sandwiches and
hot the meals and sandwiches
we ran into joe teddy emart who we first
met as i had a barrel through the city
sunday night
ferocity is tenacity
it was
bad i've been in a lot of hurricanes
complete
wreckage and cornage man every
building every structure
had damage roof damage trees falling on
it power lines down roofs
missing no water everything else is
destroyed everything's gone except my
camp
despite the devastation there's still a
sense of gratefulness for the homes that
were spared everything is gone except
your camper
how is that possible
power god this right here too
this emart grew up near houma and says
ida is no match for his love of
louisiana there are more storms that are
going to come eventually
at what point do you decide i can't live
here anymore never you want to see
america and humanity look at this place
here's the thing everybody is in the
same boat here to give you an idea of
what it takes to actually get this
report on for example there is no
electricity here there is no power right
no cell service here no running water so
just to get this report on we have one
satellite truck and one satellite phone
so we are definitely going old school
just to bring you what is happening here
in these communities but the good news
is is that when we were leaving our
hotel this morning that has no power no
lighter no running water we did see
dozens
of utility trucks that were parked at
the civic center these guys are telling
us as soon as the sun rises they are
heading out and they're going to start
working on some of those power lines to
try and get people back up and running
as soon as possible vlad and get them
that much needed relief medea thank you
very much